welcome to the live stream it is the
16th anniversary of 9/11 gonna talk a
little bit about that I'm gonna tell a
story that I've told before actually
about where I was on 9/11 16 years ago I
will be taking your questions we'll be
talking about really a lot of other
things I'm trying to get back into the
live streams I was we had David Pakman
show summer vacation sort of in the
second half of August and then it's been
so hectic since I got back with I'm now
teaching a course as an adjunct
professor at Boston College here in the
Boston area that's been incredibly busy
and just catching back up with the show
and so much different stuff going on
that it's been tough to do the live
streams but I am trying to recommit to
live streams and that is hopefully part
of what I am doing today I'll tell you a
little bit about what will be on the
program tomorrow and really a lot of
things to talk about all right so first
and foremost if this is your first live
stream live streams are live except when
they're not except when you're watching
a replay and you can use super chat
below to ask questions or to send
comments I will read them I will then
respond if it's a question I will
respond if it's a comment I will react
and that is using the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window very very easy
feel free to do that also new members
and patrons who sign up during the live
stream will get thank yous for me I will
sing your praises as if you were an
incredibly good person and by that I
mean I have no reason to think you
aren't and anybody who supports the show
I can only imagine are really the best
people they're really sending the best
people to support the show and as a
result I assume most are great people
membership you can find out about david
pakman.com slash membership patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'll
mention this later but we've launched
any number of patron benefits now it
used to be that patreon was just like
hey here's some money but enough people
complained
or suggested or demanded that patreon
come with benefits that now you actually
get the bonus show the full daily TV
show and a whole bunch of other stuff
including upcoming supporter only live
streams supporter only live streams
where everybody will get to ask
questions not just super chatters
through patreon and membership so check
that out
please don't troll okay I didn't mention
this last time because it's just kind of
been obvious that you shouldn't do it
but there are moderators prowling
lurking in the chat and they will
they've been fully deputized to ban
people who are obviously trolling or
sending hateful comments if it's subtle
we might not notice and thus you might
be able to get away with it I don't know
but that's definitely something to be
aware of so sixteen years since 9/11 I
find that every year on the program I
talk less and less about 9/11 and it's
not because it doesn't matter in fact
it's had such a huge influence on
American society in terms of security in
terms of what happens when you travel on
an airplane in terms of the
justification for surveillance right
9/11 has had a major impact there's
people now who are voting who really
don't remember 9/11 in any detail if at
all and it's not that I don't think it's
important to talk about 9/11 but
increasingly I find that I have less and
less to say on each 9/11 anniversary you
know on the the one-year anniversary I
was uh I guess senior in high school in
2002 and that felt very different than
the five and ten and 15 year anniversary
but I will tell you where I was on 9/11
I was in junior year in high school
psychology class and a student whose
name I can't believe I don't remember
had been excused to go to the bathroom
and came back in and at that point it
was probably 855 in the morning maybe
9:00 a.m. or something like that East
Coast time and he said interrupted the
class and said we're under attack
it's crazy its World War three it's a
terrorist attack or something along
those lines and he was kind of a known
troublemaker constantly disrupting the
class and our psychology teacher who has
actually recently passed away to someone
I kept in touch with after high school
said I'm sure everything's fine you've
disrupted the class enough today sit
down and let us get back to today's
class or something along those lines and
of course the student was right
something crazy had happened and the
next day I remember it like it was
yesterday even though it's been 16 years
15 years 364 days I guess the day after
this happened our psychology professor
said something along the lines of I need
to apologize too for some reason I think
maybe the name was Ehrich but I don't
remember the guys name and you know you
were right and there was a big thing
going on and I'm sorry that I reacted
the way I did and he looked around and
he said we will all probably forever
remember this situation and this guy
whose name I'm not sure of coming back
in and saying this is what happened and
me not believing in etc and I do
remember I remember like it was
yesterday
although I don't remember the guys name
I don't remember the students name
although I think that it was Eric and
whenever I tell this story often someone
knows who I'm talking about and
interestingly before our psychology
teacher did pass away a few years ago I
bumped into him and he said you know
people come up to me and they say David
Pakman says that he was in your
psychology class and that you said this
and blah blah blah is that the case and
he said I genuinely don't remember I
assumed that David's telling the truth
but I genuinely don't remember if that's
the way it went down
[Music]
and quite quite a little story and I
think people who were in a particular
place like with the Boston bombing
marathon for example which now was I
guess more than four years ago I believe
it was I think it was 2013 23rd May of
2013 I remember we had just finished at
the time we used to do the David Pakman
show I think from 1:00 to 2:00 p.m.
Eastern or 2:00 to 3:00 p.m. Eastern and
we had just finished and news was
breaking on Twitter about the Boston
Marathon bombing and we stayed at the
studio and immediately started doing
coverage and content and it was it was
quite a quite a day quite an afternoon
for sure so that's my story if anybody
else to be a super chat or whatever
wants to share their their stories I'd
be glad to share them but I don't always
is it okay to talk about 9/11 less and
less as time goes on I mean should we be
memorializing it in some I don't know
particular way every single year I think
that it's if you think we should it's
interesting to think back to something
like Pearl Harbor which I'm sure in the
5 10 and 15 years after that happened
the feeling was very different than when
a growing percentage of the people left
on the planet were not alive on that day
and sort of the meaning that it has the
meaning that it has for them I don't
know I don't know but I'm interested in
hearing your thoughts about it okay I am
now I'm involved in this new paradigm
now at the audience request where I am
drastically limiting the amount that I
talk during the live streams about both
membership and patreon and seeing
whether we get just as much buy-in from
people than when I do telethon style
David Pakman livestreams which some
people seem to enjoy and think are funny
and some people say David just talk
about politics so I'm gonna try that
again today okay last livestream I only
talked about patreon membership in the
YouTube ad boycott at the beginning
middle and end of the thing for like 30
seconds and I'm gonna try that again
today and we'll sort of see how it does
if you're not aware of what I'm
talking about there is this thing called
the YouTube ad boycott that's going on
we no longer make really any money off
of youtube
okay we've lost about 85 to 88 percent
of our YouTube ad revenue started the
year strong lost 99% of it when the
YouTube ad boycott first started looked
like things were recovering and then
things fell off a cliff and actually
actually update this chart because this
chart point four on this chart is um
July which is when it was sort of like
YouTube ad boycott part two it's gotten
even worse since then and I will update
that before the next live stream so
basically that put a big a threw a big
monkey wrench into how we would be
funding the future planned growth of the
David Pakman show so we're basically
trying to replace that revenue in two
ways number one is membership which you
sign up for at david pakman.com slash
membership there are great Members Only
benefits the members only benefits
include the commercial-free all-access
pass as well as the bonus show we do
have a 40% discount code available for
membership which is I voted 17 if you
sign up for membership during the live
stream I will tell you what a great
person you are and thank you like for
example Suzanne Hartman Suzanne Hartman
just signed up while I was chatting and
what I can tell you is Suzanne Hartman
is an incredible person a very very good
person a kind person and a person that
values independent media you can also
try a David Pakman show membership this
is new now for $1 you can get a week
trial membership for $1 at david
pakman.com slash dollar alright and then
you can decide what you want to do with
that membership you can also get these
great member benefits the commercial
free show and the bonus show through
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we are trying to get once
and for all to 2,000 patrons we were
very close at the end of August but
unfortunately at the beginning of every
new month some people's credit cards
expire and we get knocked back down to
something like eighteen hundred and
fifty patrons we are back up to nineteen
hundred and I would love your help
getting to 2,000 once we get to 2,000
I'll do an entire show
with my hair like this from the studio
which is going to be a scary event and
it will be an event that might raise
eyebrows although here in this picture
it seems like it's not so much eyebrows
that are raised but all the other hair
on my head and you can now get both the
bonus show in the commercial free TV
show as a patreon donor and I will also
do thank-yous there okay so if you want
to read more about the YouTube ad
boycott check out our press page at
david pakman.com very very good article
in Wired about what is going on with the
David Pakman show YouTube channel very
very good article in The New York Times
by Amanda Hess about what's going on
with our YouTube channel so a lot of
stuff available and going on and we will
leave it there and in a half hour I'll
check back in and we will see if we have
any new members or patrons to thank
let's jump into the super chat a little
bit then I want to talk about tomorrow's
program and also some upcoming
interviews which are really really good
that we have scheduled Jacob Ball has
sent a $20 super chat saying Clinton
states that Bernie had essentially the
same policies as she she goes on to say
Bernie was offering up far-left policies
equivalent to free ponies is there any
way these two statements do not
contradict each other okay I've been
taking a lot of heat and we actually
lost some members because some people
said I'm too critical of Hillary Clinton
and I feel as though the statements are
at face value contradictory I'll tell
you the way in which they're not and how
I see it okay on many issues Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders do share the
same policy ideas not on all issues
Hillary Clinton believes that the issues
on which they differ are the ones where
Bernie is offering the equivalent of
free ponies right free stuff with no
cost I do agree that where Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders differ it
does often have to do with economic
policy I've been critical to the extent
that I praised Bernie Sanders and voted
for him in the prime
and ultimately voted for Hillary Clinton
in the general election it's it's not
foreign policy is not Bernie strong area
right and I said Bernie looked
shell-shocked that time when they went
to him with a question about foreign
policy during during I believe it was
the first debate if not the second
foreign policy was not Bernie strong
suit economic policy I believe was and
Bernie Sanders did explain with pretty
significant specificity how he would pay
for the proposals that he had medicare
for all single-payer that's been studied
extensively in terms of the finances of
it including by by University of
Massachusetts Amherst economist Gerald
Friedman who I've interviewed on the
program from my undergraduate alma mater
UMass Amherst the free college so-called
free College Hillary Clinton saying well
I don't agree with the way Bernie's
approaching it because rich people might
also get free college and they don't
deserve it or something like that so I
do believe Jacob that Bernie Sanders did
differ with Hillary Clinton primarily on
economic policy and tended to want to
offer more but of course had ways to pay
for it and I also agree that on many
issues there was not a substantive
difference between Bernie and Hillary
now here's the sort of key thing just
because Bernie and Hillary may have
ended up with a similar or almost
identical policy position doesn't mean
that you see those policy positions the
same way meaning you could say Bernie
and Hillary have position a and I agree
with it however with Bernie I feel like
that's been his genuine position for the
last thirty years
whereas with Hillary Clinton I don't
feel like it's an authentic and genuine
position I feel like it's a position
she's taken for political posturing that
would be a totally legitimate criticism
to make if it's a bit if it's warranted
or backed by the facts on the ground so
to speak so a few thoughts there Jacob
thanks for the super chat gr has sent a
$2 super chat Irie cocked my bathtub
looks great love gr fantastic absolutely
fantastic nothing
you know the bathrooms can really be
improved by getting rid of that old and
sometimes sort of fungus covered
caulking around the tub and I fully
support what you are doing
game fire 74 cent an $11 and 2 cent
super check my friend also teaches
college classes he's a bit of an elitist
do you think some people are too stupid
for college are you patient with
students also are too many people going
to college ok
each of these questions has really a lot
to it do I think some people are too
stupid for college that's not really a
word that I try to use I think that
there's no doubt that some people's
predispositions in terms of the types of
thinking that they do well with are not
most aligned with your standard at least
liberal arts college education it
doesn't mean that they are stupid per se
right I mean that more than likely
doesn't some people just you know aren't
that intelligent and that's just a
reality there's a spectrum of human
intelligence I don't think that's
shocking for me to say but there are
definitely people who are not
unintelligent they're just better at
other types of thinking and I think
that's perfectly fine I'm very patient
with my students and are too many people
going to college there's a there's a
sort of circular issue with college
degrees on the one hand you have
requirements for jobs higher and higher
in terms of educational requirements and
that makes it so that more people decide
to go to college because they say hey if
I really want to get the job that I want
I need to go to college on the other
hand of that you also have more and more
people with degrees which makes
employers be able to say hey even though
this job used to only require a high
school diploma and then eventually an
associate's degree
we will now require a four-year degree
from everybody because there's so many
people with degrees it's very circular
and it's it becomes a sort of feedback
loop and I don't know you know I don't
know ultimately what's what's going to
happen with that part of what's
happening is that college is getting
more and more expensive and any ghost
has sent the $20 super chat
David if corporate-sponsored established
media pseudo progressive NPR can do
pledge drives then independent media
should be encouraged to do so your
voices are too important not to
I appreciate that in there and I
appreciate the $20 super chat here's the
thing I get that
most people who tuned in to the show
they just want the day's news or
whatever right I mean they they're not
tuning in to hear me talk about how we
need people to sign up for membership
and patreon so I totally get that
I think NPR and PBS people are more
aware of the fact that that's how those
are funded I think with online news
there's often the assumption that either
number one it doesn't make money because
the people doing it or doing it as
hobbies of course the David Pakman show
is a full-time job
for multiple people and so we are in a
different financial situation we do a
five day a week show we have staff we
have infrastructure we have a studio and
all this other stuff so I do agree with
you yeah it would be great if
independent media were more encouraged
to do pledge drives in that that type of
thing but at the same time I get it we
can't do too much of that because people
just tune out and that's why I'm trying
during these live streams to talk less
about membership and patreon although
I'm worried because you know the the
live streams do Drive a lot of patreon
and membership signups and last time I
tested just a couple of mentions it
didn't go that well we had far fewer
people on that live stream than we had
in other ones so I'm sort of trying it
again but I appreciate the support and I
do think that it would be better you
know a lot of people don't think about
how much they spend on cable TV although
many people record cutting or on a latte
right you hear a lot of this lot a
criticism but I think there is something
to it and if only you know 2% of our
YouTube audience through $2 a month that
us I wouldn't have to even talk about
raising money because we'd have all the
money we need and we'd have the staff we
need and everybody would be well taken
care of and we'd be in good shape you
know what I mean so that that's sort of
the reality if we could get more people
saying hey I'm probably in the top 5%
income wise let me make a little bit of
a contribution or I'm in the top 10%
income wise in the country
I can contribute a dollar or two or five
or ten then it would make a huge
difference I wouldn't have to talk about
it nearly as much Brian Finley has sent
the five British pound super chat what
do you think of the concept of the soft
bigotry of low expectations very good
question I think the concept of the soft
bigotry of low expectations is valid but
I think it is often used by the right to
criticize affirmative action or social
welfare programs targeted at certain
populations so let's see if we can break
it down there's no question that
expecting less of people based on race
ethnicity national origin whatever right
that is a form of bigotry in other words
to say I am going to expect less of X or
Y because they are and I'll just pick
something because I'm from Argentina and
I'm a immigrant to the United States
because someone's South American right
South American moves to the US I'm an
expected less of them because they're
South American that is a form of bigotry
which you're saying I'm not even going
to hold them to as high a standard
because I already am seeing them as less
capable or whatever the case may be
totally agree however you often see
right-wingers take it even further and
say and as a result we should get rid of
affirmative action because affirmative
action is the is a sort of bigotry by
saying certain groups need more help
merely because we see them as having
lower potential because of whatever
identifying factor class membership you
want to say and there's nothing bigoted
about saying hey hold on a second if we
consider historical oppression and
discrimination and segregation and so
many other elements of society
affirmative action is not meant to give
an advantage it's meant to be an
equalizer okay and so really good
question you you know it's it's kind of
a it's a tough thing because with a lot
of these issues the right has sort of
cornered the mark
it on the simple talking points when the
reality is much more complicated and
nuanced is way less compelling than
angry talking points and it's something
that the left has to contend with think
about taxes right hey taxes are the
government stealing from you that's your
money lower taxes are better the liberal
position isn't taxes are great and we
should maximize taxes that would be sort
of the opposite but it's not the
progressive position it's well taxes are
necessary for a well-functioning Society
with many of the common resources that
we all take for granted and we should
make sure that we are taxing the
population appropriately but not in a
way that goes overboard right it's not
as quick as hey that's your money take
your money back and I think that that
that's also relevant with this concept
of the the bigotry of low expectations
Jacob ball has sent a five-dollar super
chatter will you be seeking permission
to post your lectures on your channel I
think a lot of your subscribers would be
interested in seeing them yeah I think
that what Jacob is referring to my
lectures at the class I'm teaching at
Boston College and I you know this is
the first year I'm teaching and it's the
first year that the class I'm teaching
is being taught so I'm taking this as a
sort of get up to speed semester and I
don't plan and the lectures haven't been
filmed that I'm aware of and I don't
plan to post them from this semester but
I'd be open to looking at that if I am
invited to teach a class again
particularly if it's this class then
that's certainly something I would look
at doing Christina with a $2.00 super
chat what do you do for exercise okay
let's see so in the summer typically I
run outside and then I will also swim I
have a gym membership and I will swim a
half mile at a time I guess I what I
mean is a half mile in a day per session
or something like that and what else do
I do and I'll do some weights at the gym
in the winter I'll usually run
inside at the gym I try to swim but I
feel less like swimming when it's
freezing and I'll do weights that's
basically it and then sporadically I've
been in social sports leagues like you
know basically beer leagues I did a
soccer one when I lived in Brooklyn and
I might do volleyball here in Boston
biking bicycle as much as I can
I went for a nice 15 mile ride on Sunday
in fact I think that's mostly a No
gr popping up with a $2.00 super chat
Pakman in is not a crime
love gr couldn't have said it better
myself gr absolutely could not have said
it better myself
okay I want to tell you about some of
the interviews that are coming up on the
program because there's some really good
stuff coming up first of all tomorrow on
the broadcast show we will be releasing
and broadcasting our long-form
investigation into both voter fraud and
voter suppression now you will notice
that one of those things is real and the
other isn't you probably know which is
which and tomorrow we will be doing our
long-form piece on that a lot of
audience proposed interviews coming up
on Wednesday I'll be interviewing Steve
Lido or Leto he's a lawyer who
specializes in automotive law and this
includes warranties lemon law car sale
law he wrote a book called the lemon law
Bible and he's got a podcast and he came
highly recommended by a number of our
viewers and listeners and I'm going to
be interviewing him on Wednesday which i
think is gonna be absolutely fantastic
and then I am really looking forward to
this on Thursday I'm going to be
interviewing Blake Crouch I recently
read the book dark matter a great sci-fi
book by Blake Crouch very very dark
incredibly dark sci-fi book and I'm
going to be interviewing him on Thursday
he's also the screenwriter and I believe
producer of the program wayward Pines
which is also based on a series of books
so I'm really really excited about that
now here is where I need your help okay
I've got an interview coming up next
week with the fired Google employee that
guy James d'amour who was fired by goo
after a memo that he wrote criticizing
the diversity policy of Google went
viral
he interestingly he reached out to us
saying he's a fan of the David Pakman
show of course I don't know specifically
whether that's true or not but okay
James de Moura said he's a fan of the
David Pakman show he said he'd be
interested in being on I'm interested in
speaking to him he has said in other
interviews with less progressive hosts
that he hasn't been doing interviews on
left-wing media because he hasn't been
invited so I invited him and we were
gonna be interviewing him next week I
want your suggestions for questions for
James d'amour because there is a lot to
discuss there was a lot to discuss with
James d'amour and I think it's gonna be
really really interesting to speak to
him and you know if this ends up I see
somebody in the chat saying this is his
15 minutes of fame for James d'amour I
think that the story is interesting
because of what it has become it has
become representative it has become sort
of it embodies the battle for free
speech or something like that for some
people on the right and I don't know
that I think that's what it is so I will
speak to James de Moura he has not
exerted any limitations and what I can
ask or what we're going to talk about I
think it's gonna be really good please
reach out to me if you have particular
questions for James d'amour okay
Cristina with a follow-up super chat do
any of your students watch or listen to
the show I don't know the answer to that
Cristina I genuinely don't know the
answer to that I mean I did certainly
introduce myself in class and explain
Who I am and what I do and why I'm
teaching a class on the subject of talk
media I do not know whether students in
my class watch the David Pakman show or
not okay and then to finalize the
interview schedule which is really
really good next week no wait a second
next week is James d'amour the following
week I will be interviewing number one
Elizabeth Kolbert do I have a book here
I don't Elizabeth Kolbert wrote the book
the sixth extinction and I recently read
it this was a book that Barack Obama
read and it's a book that Barack Obama
recommended and it is about whether the
US I'm sorry whether the earth is in a
sixth major extinction right now above
and beyond what's called the background
level of species extinction the book
argues that we are and Elizabeth Kolbert
has agreed to be on the program and I'll
be honest she's pretty in demand she
writes for the New York or this book is
a book that has done incredibly well I
was sort of surprised that she got back
to me as quickly as she did and said I'd
be glad to do it and we will be doing an
interview with her and also I will be
interviewing Ken Caldeira ken caldera is
an expert so when we talk about climate
change there's many aspects to climate
change and because of the hurricanes
recently we've been talking a lot about
how hurricanes are connected to climate
change and specifically the warming of
the oceans ken caldera is an expert in
ocean acidification which is that with
climate change we have seen ocean water
become more acidic and this is part of
why we are seeing changes negative
changes to ocean life diversity and
population and ken caldera is going to
be joining us in two weeks and I think
it's also going to be an absolutely
absolutely fantastic interview well
thank you somebody letting me know my
shirt sleeve has become folded okay so
that is what's coming up as far as
interviews go let me do something I've
been trying to make it a habit to do
which is to go through the regular chat
to not just do super chats I want to get
to questions from everybody somebody
asking in the regular chat how to super
chat it's the dollar sign at the bottom
of the chat window what other questions
do we have here all right not a lot of
questions a lot of comments somebody
asking whether this is real life I
believe that it is although it could be
living in a simulation more questions
about how to send super chats have
already
address that when somebody saying I
should not say people passed away I
should say they died I didn't know that
that was a controversial thing I really
didn't but okay I will think about how I
refer to people no longer being alive
what other questions do we have here if
you are scared of less new members or
patrons why don't you try a non stop
banner at the bottom of the screen
asking people to sign up so you don't
have to talk about it yeah you know so
well actually let me talk about a couple
tech things for the livestreams last
time people suggested that I use let me
just check I want to make sure I name
the company correctly extreme labs that
I use stream labs for many of the
functions of the live stream including
receiving donations so I don't have to
so YouTube doesn't get its cut of the
super chats I've looked into stream labs
it seems you can do a lot of interesting
things including putting up graphics at
the bottom I don't totally understand
how yet though so I actually have a note
on my to-do list for tomorrow to check
out how to use stream labs like could I
directly connect stream labs to patreon
so that it will show a running tally of
patrons and thanked people or membership
or whatever how does it work I have no
idea I'm gonna try to figure it out so
good idea that's from Miranda Philippine
let's see what else do we have in the
regular chat here not that many
questions but I'm glad to see people
talking a couple people saying they're
already subscribed do I even lift I lift
a little bit will I ask the auto law guy
about the auto loan bubble yeah we've
actually talked about that and I think
that would be a good idea can someone
send David a lifetime HBO membership you
know I have so much stuff to watch
already I don't even know that I would
get a chance to watch the great content
on HBO I'd suggest if you'd want to make
a contribution patreon or membership or
the way to go people wanting me to talk
about Game of Thrones which is sort of
become a thing because I revealed
recently that I've never seen an entire
episode of a game of Thrones and I don't
feel like I'm missing anything because I
just don't know what it is I've seen 15
minutes and I was like
I'm not really into the genre and
everybody tells me you don't understand
it's a phenomenon you've got to watch it
it's international etc but I just have
never found myself drawn in and again
because I don't have HBO I don't have an
easy means of watching it
okay let's interrupt the livestream now
that we are half an hour in just to do
some thank yous I am limiting this to
just the beginning middle and end new
members a few new members
Jessica Grady and James Andrew those are
the only two new members that I have
here to say thank you to and sadly I
have zero new patrons to thank we
started the livestream today with 1,900
patrons we are trying to get ultimately
to 2,000 patrons and we still sit at
1900 patrons please get those donations
in memberships everybody will be thanked
that I promise you folks that I can
absolutely promise you
donations patreon membership the entire
thing okay on the program tomorrow in
addition to our long-form piece about
voter fraud and voter suppression number
one do you remember actually this I
should take a sip of water
the story's so insane that I need to
hydrate remember years ago when a
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi was
starting to look into the Trump
University scam and that's what it is
it's a total scam Florida Attorney
General Republican Pam Bondi was looking
into Trump University because complaints
had started to be filed against Trump
University and lo and behold and this
part I already told you about Donald
Trump ended up making a donation from
his Charitable Foundation which by the
way is legally prohibited from donating
to political campaigns made a big
contribution to a group that supported
Pam Bondi's campaign they later ended up
having to pay a fine that the Trump
foundation for that donation and all of
a sudden Pam Bondi three weeks later
said we are closing down the
investigation into Trump University well
it turns out that Pam Bondi has now
accepted a position with a Presidential
Commission effectively working for
Donald Trump and we're gonna dig into
that tomorrow by the way the Florida
afloat that this is not the only example
of weird donations and contributions
related to Donald Trump in connection to
suspiciously timed very near to the
ending of investigations into Trump
University okay we will talk about that
tomorrow
number two very odd story in Japan there
was a press conference to talk about the
danger posed by ticks and they brought
in a live tick and all of a sudden the
tick was gone and the entire room filled
with press and people organizing the
press conference was in a panicked way
looking for the live tick and it's it's
an absolutely bizarre story it's from a
few days ago I want to talk about that
tomorrow
and then also tomorrow I will be talking
about Donald Trump received a whole
bunch of gifts from Saudi Arabia when he
visited and of course the gifts were
formally accepted by the White House on
the behalf of Donald Trump which keeps
it all legal it's insane the stuff that
Donald Trump got from Saudi Arabia and
of course with Donald Trump there's
always a double standard close behind
because he criticized Hillary Clinton
from receiving money from Saudi Arabia
because they're just so terrible and the
things they do to gay people and to
women and to all these other minority
groups and Trump shows up and accepts
all of these gifts from Saudi Arabia and
while he is on that Middle East trip I
don't remember if it was specifically in
Saudi Arabia or later when he arrived in
Israel I believe that was the order of
the trip all of a sudden there's a
hundred and ten billion dollar arms sale
to Saudi Arabia from the US authorized
by Trump which is part of a three
hundred and fifty billion dollar arms
deal that
go over the next 10 years or something
like that the guy is such a hypocrite
and it is so pathetic
it is truly so pathetic that he I don't
know of anything that Donald Trump has
criticized others for that he is not
guilty of himself I'm trying to think
about it he's criticized others of you
know grabbing women by the [ __ ] or
rather he said everybody does it and of
course he treats women poorly as well
he says Saudi Arabia is bad people
shouldn't accept money from Saudi Arabia
but of course he accepts all sorts of
stuff and does business with Saudi
Arabia he talks about how it is other
people who are filling administration's
with lobbyists and corporate tools and
he says he's going to drain the swamp
but of course he does the exact same
thing when he is hired it is it is
absolutely stunning and the cognitive
dissonance that we're seeing with Trump
supporters is glaring I mean it is it
they are ideologically committed to a
degree that it doesn't matter what he
does they are going to support him and
this is why and we've been getting more
and more calls about this I do not
believe that it really is a good use of
time to debate politics with anybody who
still supports Donald Trump and by still
supports what I mean is we've seen
Trump's approval rating sort of drop and
I believe that the people who supported
Trump doesn't mean they voted for him
but people who supported or approved if
the job he was doing who no longer do
they're probably somewhere connected to
reality the people who still support
Trump or would vote for re-election you
would have to spend a lot of time with
each of them to even have a shot at
changing their mind about supporting
Donald Trump with only 50% voter turnout
in the last election pragmatically
speaking just try to get more people to
vote right you're going to be able to
spend X amount of time and you will be
much more effective spending that amount
of time getting people to vote in 2018
and 2020 then convincing Trump voters to
vote for someone else and
just don't think it's worth it it's good
you're gonna drive yourself completely
crazy first of all and I don't think it
will be particularly effective I don't
think it will be particularly effective
because they are so ideologically
committed don't don't bother just work
on get out the vote that's my view okay
let me jump into the regular chat here
and deal with a few more questions that
are going on let's see do you think
Congress will save Daka genuinely no
idea genuinely no idea what is your
opinion on the Senators intending to
co-sponsor Bernie Sanders Medicare for
all bill I think that that's fantastic I
will update you on that tomorrow and
also I am slightly concerned about how
Bernie's Medicare for all bill will be
written I believe we're gonna find out
on Wednesday I don't know if we will
find out early Wednesday so that I can
talk about it on Wednesday's show or if
not I will do an analysis of Bernie's
medicare-for-all bill on Thursday I'm
worried that it's not really a
medicare-for-all bill and the reason I
say that is I read a couple of articles
from people claiming to have knowledge
of the bills writing saying that it is
not truly going to be Medicare for all a
single-payer bill we will see okay do I
believe anyone will serve jail time in
the Trump administration you know I
actually believe someone will but that
it will be totally symbolic that it will
be effectively meaningless but I think
someone will end up serving jail time
ask the former Google employee the
question about what was the purpose for
sending out that email I'm an author and
that's one of my topics I'm really
interested to understand him uh yeah I
mean that's a fair question what even if
what did James d'amore believe he would
accomplish by sending out that email
complaining about criticizing the Google
diversity policy how isn't it on doing
is he's still in Israel No okay so
former TV director natandy ecwid was
studying in Israel for thirteen months
doing his master's degree I visited him
there during that time he is no longer
studying in Israel he is working in the
city of Los Angeles California he's
actually coming to visit
Massachusetts next week so I will be
seeing him let's
see what else we've got has David never
heard of the Pirate Bay
I have heard about it thank you I don't
know if the question was related to
something in particular would I support
a Tulsi Gabbard presidency on principle
alone
I have declined to talk about 2020
presidential candidates for now beyond
expressing concern that so many
Democratic donors and insiders seem to
be anointing California senator camel
Harris as the 2020 candidate but I don't
think it makes sense to talk about that
right now same question too soft a Sunni
or sunny who said what do I think of Joe
Kennedy for president I think it's too
early I think it's too early to talk
about that there is a lot that needs to
happen between now and then okay Richard
Oh has sent a to British pound super
Chad what is the the difference between
Trump voters and Trump anzhi's okay so
if by Trump and Z you mean someone who
is ideologically committed to Donald
Trump no matter what I think
that a trump voter by now if they are
reasonable will have realized that it's
a totally abortive attempt at a
presidency and they are no longer
supporting Trump a trump Anssi if that's
what you're calling them will never
cease supporting Donald Trump
Athena Harding has sent a $20 super
check Jeff Sessions is still in office
do you still think he's on the way out I
think that Jeff Sessions may have been
under the under the radar long enough
where he is no longer in the crosshairs
of Donald Trump and he may be safe note
that Jeff Sessions I think is sort of
like the only remaining link to
establishment Republicans right because
so many people have are just gone from
the Trump administration I think that in
a way Jeff Sessions needs to stay for
Trump to really have a credible
connection to the mainstream Republican
Party Jacob ball has sent a $2 super
chat have you read James de
more's memo yes I have although it's
been several weeks I read it at the time
that it was released in the entire
controversy blew up I will read it again
and probably quote from it during my
interview next week with James d'amour
ok says ikan Alice has sent a 15 dollar
super jet thank you says he says he I
believe is a David Pakman show
all-star meaning that she I think is a
member regular super chatter and patron
I think that she supports the show
through all three means and I'm gonna be
totally upfront the patreon and
membership signups during the livestream
are falling flat very very flat we've
had 0 patreon contributions during the
stream despite the fact that we've added
both membership benefits both of the
major membership benefits which are
bonus show access every day we do a
Members Only show which now is also
available to patrons at the five-dollar
level and the full hour TV show which
normally you've got to wait for like 12
hours to see in parts we offer that as a
patreon benefit at the $10 level and
we've had 0 new patrons during the
stream which is really really bad I know
some people don't like the telethons but
I might have to go back to the telethon
live streams because we are in real we
are in a complex financial situation and
the live streams were providing some
hope to me that we would ultimately be
able to recover from the financial
impasse caused by YouTube ad pocalypse
and sadly when I just sporadically
mentioned patreon and membership we get
very very few very very few
contributions that way so that's that's
not good that is not good as the kids
these days would say let me talk about a
couple other things I want to hear from
you about ideas for
long-form investigative type videos
we've done these videos on everything
from undocumented immigration to
political correctness the regressive
left voter suppression socialism and
communism violence committed by the
political left we've done a dozen or
more of these at this point I want your
help
in guiding the future of the long-form
pieces right now a David Pakman show
producer Noah Ferguson is working on I
know this is a controversial issue I
think it's going to do really really
well
when we are finished with this piece
race and IQ racin IQ is actually a topic
that's been around for a long time it
has an ugly past that relates to
eugenics and a lot of other really
really horrible stuff it reappeared sort
of prominently in political discussion
because Sam Harris did an interview with
this Murray guy first name I'm blanking
on who wrote the bell curve and is it
Douglas Murray the bell curve Murray and
I know I'm gonna feel so stupid when I
Charles Murray
Douglas Murray is someone else yeah
charles Murray wrote this book about the
bell curve connecting intelligence to
race anyway we're doing a deep dive it
is
I heard from Noah Ferguson about this
today we spoke about it he said it is
very mathematically intensive and we are
doing a really good piece on it and
don't think for a second we're only
going to talk about the merits of the
argument we're going to talk about why
or if it makes a difference in terms of
thinking about public policy okay so
that's a really really good piece send
me your thoughts ideally through the
website about what other pieces we
should consider doing we've got a lot of
stuff planned gr has sent the $2 super
chat I am a good salesman employ me for
free love gr alright well I don't know
exactly what it what I would employ you
for I become flummoxed by gr super chats
very often
I don't know how do I don't know how to
handle it basically Jordan Barnard has
sent a two dollar super chat with no
question or comment thank you very much
oh I see and Jordan then Jordan sent the
$2 super chat but then asked this
question in regular chat saying David do
you watch the Netflix show narcos I
think it's a good example of why drugs
should be legalized taxed and regulated
how about a long-form piece on the war
on drugs that is a good idea long form
piece on the war on drugs and in fact
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do you one better
Jordan if I can find our shared document
that we use internally for ideas yes
here it is I'm going to add that the war
on drugs all right very very good idea
so we will be we will consider that I
have watched season one of narcos I got
a little album this is such a dumb thing
in a way what made the program difficult
for me to watch is so I'm a native
Spanish speaker having been born in
Argentina and of course Pablo Escobar
was Colombian and he spoke Spanish
natively the actor who plays at least in
the first season I don't know where the
program went the actor who plays Pablo
Escobar in the first season of narcos is
Brazilian and he speaks Spanish with an
accent with a non-native speaker accent
and it becomes just annoying to me that
there's no way Pablo Escobar would be
speaking that way and you know we see
this often in American movies where if
you have characters who would be
speaking French they speak English but
with a French accent and that's really
annoying this is next-level annoying
where you have them speaking the native
language but with an accent that doesn't
actually make any sense so that's
actually why I dropped it but people
have been telling me that it continues
to be really good so I should probably
get back into it
Miranda Philippine has sent a five euro
super chat just rewarding you reading
out my remark from the regular chat
earlier greetings from the Netherlands
great to hear from you love the
Netherlands
I have only visited so where have I
I've been to two places in the
Netherlands I've been to Amsterdam one
of my favourite cities I mean just
stunning stunning city beautiful city
great food great people loved it and I
have been to Ma strict which is a tiny
city big town I don't even know what to
call it
sandwiched between Brussels Germany and
France and I spent a day there in April
during my trip to Belgium and it was
tremendous absolutely tremendous and
great great country okay
Brenna B has sent a five dollar super
jet have you ever said no to questions
like would you ever interview or debate
someone should people just make
suggestions and if instead of asking
would you you can phrase it however you
want Brenna yes sometimes I've said no
because I don't think it's a good fit
for the show and I think it's maybe too
niche or not interesting or I'm
genuinely completely uninterested but
generally you know I'm open to
suggestions
for interviews and a lot of the
interviews that appear on the program
are originally suggested by people in
the audience so please suggest them and
by the way I don't know how many of you
are on our reddit discussion forum but
at david pakman.com slash read it there
is a sticky thread what are the most
controversial topics right now you can
put suggestions for long-form videos in
there and you can also put suggestions
in there for interviews that you think
should be done but it's also good to
just email me you can email me
suggestions for both interviews and
long-form pieces always welcome them and
and very often I think that there are
good ideas Rico or dounia's has sent a
$2.00 super chat with you on narcos did
my tío pablo wrong okay yes alluding to
Pablo Escobar's being his uncle but yeah
agreeing with me that having a Brazilian
actor play Pablo Escobar speaking
accented non native Spanish hurts the
authenticity of course if you don't
speak Spanish and you're reading
subtitles it wouldn't affect you
Christina $2 super chat Oh
have you ever visited a bad city with
bad food I've not visited any bad cities
all cities I've list I've visited I sort
of plan - and research so I know that
I'm going to like them I have been to
places that didn't have great food okay
I you know what I'm just gonna say what
they are because it really what's the
difference right I'm not saying the
people there are bad I'm gonna name an
American city that I didn't find the
cuisine to be too good at and I'm gonna
name an international city with caveats
I went to Detroit for Netroots nation a
few years ago the food scene was not
very good we were in the downtown area
the group we were with people from Sam
cedar was there people from The Young
Turks people from Ring of Fire and most
nights we were getting dinner together
it was pretty tough it was pretty tough
and there were a couple of restaurant
announcements that restaurants that were
coming but it was not it was not the
best and I won't mention anywhere that
we went now here's a more controversial
one other than the Indian food
I found London cuisine not to be very
good okay and I think that there were
two aspects to it one is that London
cuisine the standard London pub menu
which is sort of like the default thing
you find a place you randomly go into is
not I don't want to be an offensive to
anybody but it has a lot of overlap with
Boston Irish pubs and I'm kind of sick
of it so that was part of it but also I
just I genuinely didn't think it was
that good but I had the best Indian food
and different types of Indian food in my
life in London really really good Indian
food and for people asking I am NOT
vegan and I am also not vegetarian okay
so yeah those would be my two thoughts a
couple more questions from the regular
chat do I know anyone with dementia yes
I do I do
I I have both friends and I have
numerous friends who have family members
dealing with Alzheimer's and dementia I
also
you know I probably have some of my
older relatives who are dealing with
what would be called subclinical
dementia which means like they've not
been formally diagnosed with dementia or
Alzheimer's but due to advanced age and
just sort of deterioration they probably
have slight subclinical dementia okay
here is another one of these I don't
know what's going on where people are
sending a suit a blank super chat and
then asking the question in the regular
chat maybe it's in order to get a longer
question very very clever Adrienne M has
sent a $2.00 super chat and a question
in Spanish which I will read in Spanish
and then translate and then answer okay
david krejci los equipos america
Davidian doubling cardinal proxy mundial
a por que no tienen paseo de granada
okay so I think the question is should
and I think by America you mean the
United States do I believe that the US
Men's National Team should skip the
following two World Cups because they
don't have realistic possibilities of
winning I don't know if that's true I
mean I just I don't follow the US Men's
National Team I follow the Argentinean
men's national team and in fact I should
see how that's going World Cup let's
just figure out how everybody's doing
World Cup qualifier standings and we'll
figure out how the US is doing World Cup
qualifying okay looks like it defaults
to Europe let me look at how can I get
out of Europe here and qualifiers
matches I'm looking for standings here
and this is difficult statistics
statistics overview no that's not it
either I guess I have to go by region
okay so let's start with North Central
America and Caribbean how is the u.s.
doing it's the u.s. in place right now
to go to the World Cup I mean if you're
it looks like they're tied for fourth in
their group unless I'm reading this
incorrectly so now why would they get
out they should stay in
let's see how things are going in South
America for Argentinian Argentina I
haven't looked at the standings one two
three
so basically tied right now for fourth
and fifth place with Peru points-wise
Peru has more goals and thus way ahead
of Argentina in terms of points yeah so
listen I don't know what the US should
do I am the last person who should be
talking about what it is that the US
men's national team should do but they
should do what's best for them all right
okay Nico's rap has sent a $2 super chat
as a teenager can I volunteer or intern
with you in some way but listen the best
way to volunteer is to help promote
clips of the program online oh not goals
goals differential I apologize yeah goal
differential is what matters their goal
differential vs. your opponents listen
Nico there's no we don't really have a
formal way for you to intern remotely
but the best thing you can do and if
everybody did this the show would be
huge share clips of the show share clips
of the show that you think are value
we'll share them on social media share
them any way you can stand outside with
a screen shot actually that would be
funny and it would probably make the
show stand outside with a screen shot of
a youtube video as people drive by
getting the word out on the show is
really the best the best thing you can
do any ghost has sent a ten dollar super
chat David you've asserted that Jill
Stein is nutty are we not all safer with
her nutty than the established natty of
someone like Clinton who advocating
escalating tensions with Russia and the
military III can't do the full thing on
Jill Stein right now but needless to say
here's the way I feel I voted for
Hillary Clinton on November 8th in
Massachusetts not for any political
posturing or strategic voting reason I
genuinely believe that of the four
people that were on the ballot that she
was the best candidate and I have a long
long long list of criticisms of Hillary
Clinton I'll answer the question that
way cm COC has sent a what is this I
believe is is this called 20,000 column
and peso super chat how much is that
let's see 20000 Co P 2 USD I have no
idea how much that is 6.84 cents okay
thank you
FARC peace protests in Colombia and the
violations of the agreements so far long
form peace suggestion on the narco
subject watched the original Colombian
production a but they run the mile far
superior interesting is that on Netflix
I wonder I'll open that up and take a
look I did not know about that series
but I will check it out okay let's see
any ghosts $10 super chat intervention
in Syria continuing the pointless war on
marijuana not supporting a living wage
and continuing to attempt regime change
which with her Iraq war voting history
oh this is the follow-up to the question
about Hillary Clinton listen I don't
defend the policies of Hillary Clinton
in total and in fact there's many
policies I don't defend at all and I
voted for Bernie Sanders in the primary
but I believe that Jill Stein was
completely and totally out of her
element
I think that she has dangerous positions
on some issues probably due to ignorance
more than her being a bad person and
Jill Stein is not someone that I would
support okay
video editor Scott has sent a regular
chat message saying your main show audio
is always muddy get rid of those mics
and the mic you're using now is crystal
clear I don't know about that every once
in a while I will get one complaint like
every few months about the regular show
audio and then I'll ask the audience
about it no one else seems to agree that
it's an issue and I think our in-studio
mics really sound pretty good
I really do i this is not a very good
mic although if somebody is a video or
rather audio tech we are running our EVR
e 20s through dbx 286s errs and there
might be a setting in the processor that
might
making it a little muddy I've got the
low end completely off the compressors
not particularly high so if you have if
you're if you're really knowledgeable
about this let me know because I'm
willing to make some adjustments there
Sean Maguire has sent the five-dollar
super jet have you ever thought have you
ever watched the real news with Paul Jay
if so what are your thoughts on their
ideological slant I did a panel in New
York City I hosted a panel at left forum
last year Paul Jay was on the panel from
the real news along with Sam cedar and
Ben Dixon and it was a really great
panel the real news is not my cup of tea
and I've never hidden that from anybody
the real news is not my cup of tea and I
do not I am not in line with their exact
brand of progressivism I'm not saying I
disagree with them on everything or even
nearly everything but it's not it's not
my thing
okay so that is not that's kind of where
I am okay let me do a big thank you we
have received one one patreon
contribution during this entire
livestream and it is a $10 a month
contribution from Michael Jenks
Michael Jenks has made a $10
contribution which gets gets us from
1900 patrons today at the start of the
stream to 1901 also no new members in
addition to the ones I already mentioned
for today's livestream so that's that's
sad that's disappointing and I am
totally open to not doing the telethon
style let's get to this number etc etc
but the live streams are an opportunity
to raise some funds and it's sort of I'm
bummed out I'm bummed out that the that
it didn't go better but that is the end
of today's live stream I will stream
again and please do make those
contributions we're trying to fix this
this is the problem we're trying to fix
with YouTube revenue and every
contribution gets us a dollar closer to
bridging that gap